I was recently watching Bill Birds
latest stand-up special on Netflix
brilliant comedian loved billboard and I
stumbled upon a setting in their app
that I'd never heard of before this is
true it's called audio descriptions has
anyone seen this it adds voice
narrations that describe everything is
happening on screen for the blind or for
people who want to listen to a show like
it's an audiobook okay and I was
watching this and it's really
fascinating this is real these are some
honest-to-god true examples from Bill
Birds latest special on Netflix just
check this out bill burr paper tiger the
backstage of a theatre white letters
appear recorded live at the Royal Albert
Hall London England
[Applause]
a middle-aged bald man strides out onto
a stage facing a large audience he
removes a microphone from its stand
Donald Trump's wife stands behind him
like a giant meerkat like bill pulls his
hands up to his chest like a meerkat he
shakes a fist in front of his crotch
they did I was that's all real I was
watching that yeah I was watching that
and listening to it and it got me
thinking I also have some specials on
Netflix my Conan without borders travel
shows so I was curious I had to find out
I wanted to hear what the audio
descriptions were for the stuff that I
do on Netflix so I checked it out a
gangly ghost of a man emerges from
abroad and walks for camera while
appropriating culture he appears to be
both prepubescent and 100 years old the
man begins to dance
please note I'm saying dance like it's
in quotes he then sits at a table and
waves to a boy who makes no effort to
hide his disdain for the man surrounded
by some of the country's greatest
warriors the clown without a circus
takes center stage to see how quickly he
can disrespect thousands of years of
honor and tradition the barely
functioning ventriloquist dummy
punches through a thin slice of cookie
waiver painted to look like plywood
the pasty man with looks that no amount
of alcohol could improve samples wine
with his on camera hostages of the day
the redheaded fool channels the
resentments he feels about his parents
and directs them toward his producer the
handsome and long-suffering Jordan CH
landscape in what can only be described
as an improvement the human rooster
dresses as a human rooster unfortunately
unlike the chickens in the
slaughterhouse this roosters execution
does not come quickly and the onlookers
are forced to endure his nonstop clucks
or attention
yeah